The joe rogan experience.
So I might not recognize it,
but that's just,
I don't even know why speculated
fucking wasted all your time.
Joe Rogan says,
keep on questioning everything.
You can't stop on that show.
The question
with the one with,
with the,
with chem trails,
I don't know either way,
I'm not fucking up there.
But there is a difference between
the ones that that do dissipate.
Correct.
You know right away and
the ones that stick around.
Well again,
I say absolutely not a scientist nor
in anything that I will say on any,
whether it's about fucking air
travel or space exploration,
anything that I'll say on anything,
the caveat that it must be stated is
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about.
I have no education,
these subjects and I'm merely reiterating
things that I've heard people say
online that's like,
if you were to say that
everyone would think so though.
You know what I mean?
You sound confident about the problem.
Problem.
It's awesome.
I sound like an idiot.
Well,
it's just,
especially if I'm wrong and I'm super
confident that that's how called get
started again.
The,
um,
yeah,
people are confident people
want to listen to them,
but I'm super honest about
what I know and I don't know.
I'm fucking as honest
as as humanly possible,
even if it makes it look like an asshole.
But in that situation,
I do know for a fact that when,
when Khan trails or more likely
there's a map on a NASA website,
you can go to the NASA website and they'll
show you where controls will linger
in the sky and where they won't.
In fact,
in 1942,
the government was doing a research
project on what they called persistent
condensation trails.
And what they discovered is during
various atmosphere conditions,
whether there's a lot of moisture
in the atmosphere or less moisture,
depending on what the conditions are,
it will change the length of the
contracts that appear behind jets.
And when you burn jet fuel,
it creates moisture.
And when you create moisture out of
that burning jet fuel and it changes the
temperature of the air as
it passes through like that,
you literally create a cloud.
And so when people are looking
at that and they're thinking,
oh,
the government spraying
us with fake clouds,
it's very easy to think
that it's very easy.
And this does not mean that they haven't
done tests and really unethical things
with spraying aerosols from planes.
We know they have,
we know that pesticides
are sprayed from planes.
Okay,
so we've,
we're,
we're familiar.
We have that archetype in
our head of spraying poison.
We've seen the footage from Vietnam when
they sprayed agent orange to defoliate
vast parts in jungles.
We've seen all that shit.
So we're wary of things that are
sprayed from planes and you should be,
but you should also know that there is
a huge difference between that and what
you're seeing in the
sky in a regular basis.
And when you start saying that,
what you're seeing this guy on a regular
basis is the government's spraying
chemicals.
You really throw a monkey wrench into
the whole idea of them actually spraying
chemicals.
Because first of all,
if the,
the,
the argument is they're
spraying of aluminum and Barium.
Again,
I'm not a scientist.
I'm half retarded.
Again,
it took a lot shots to
the head as a youngster.
But the reality is if they did spray
aluminum and Barium and the sky wouldn't
linger like a cloud,
it's a lingering like a
cloud because it's a cloud.
And I know a lot of people have invested
a long amount of their life wanting to
think that what they're
seeing is chemicals.
And so it fucks with you because
it's hard to admit you're wrong.
It's hard to change gears.
We all know that.
Correct.
But in this situation,
we have to look at it.
There might be times when someone's
spraying something from the sky,
but the majority of what you're seeing
is just a byproduct of a jet engine going
through condensation.
And then there's the reality.
People say,
well,
are they geoengineering?
No,
but yes.
So here's the reality.
The reality is,
even though it's just an
accidental byproduct of jet travel,
it does change the environment
and it is geoengineering.
But it's not on purpose,
not on purpose.
It's just a part of flying.
If we're going to have,
there's 93,000 fucking
flights a day worldwide a day.
So they're burning jet fuel
in the sky above your head.
They're taking toxic fuel in fucking
hundred gallon wings full of this shit.
Your wings are filled up with fucking
fuel and they're burning that shit up in
the sky and creating clouds.
Fuck yeah.
It changes the environment,
but it's just like pollution
changes the environment.
In La when you're driving on the highway,
it's not the government's
spraying pollution.
Okay?
It's fucking pollution.
It's just a byproduct of
human civilization and a
byproduct of air travel is a,
they're burning jet
fuel in the sky and be,
it creates persistent condensation trails
under certain atmospheric conditions.
This is the best that I could discern
after research and talking to real
experts,
but this does it and
this is where he'll go.
You're a fucking douche information
urgent Joe brokers working for the
government.
You've got to stop and look at this shit
rationally if you're wrong about the
majority of what you see in the sky,
you discredit the possibility,
the very real possibility
that things have been done.
Like there's a study about Saint Louis,
I think it was Saint Louis.
Hold on.
Let me,
let me pull this up.
St Louis,
there was a something that was in the
news really recently that they discovered
radiation.
I think chem trails or
just an excuse for pansies.
I'm just that like to look at
clouds and they went something like,
like a reason.
It was a beautiful,
I'm just curious how,
what,
why,
why some stick around and why some don't.
Okay,
so they're here.
Well this is because of
atmospheric conditions.
There's a difference between,
sometimes it rains and
sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes there's clouds,
sometimes there's nothing.
This guy,
the conditions apparently when
it's right before a crowd,
like it's Kinda hazy.
Those are the conditions that are
best for creating these persistent
condensation trails and people have to
understand these are fucking southwest
airlines flights you're looking at.
Sometimes we put these either these are,
you know,
unmarked government planes.
Man.
Do you really know that?
What kind of fucking,
Eric,
what kind of telescoped you have?
How much research have you
actually done or are you like me?
Do you just reiterate you that you learn
online will doing this show and doing
the show on chem trails?
More people got fucking mad at
me because of Cantrell's trails.
Then anything,
and I take part of the blame for that.
One of the reasons why is because I
think they did a shitty job of editing it
and this is no disrespect,
but the way that people edit that show,
they have eight hours of footage.
They have to slam down to 44 minutes.
To them it wasn't important to totally
completely explain what what causes the
chem trail.
I didn't have 100% say
or a contrail rather.
I didn't have 100% say as
to how the show got edited.
I had say after the fact,
I would voice my opinion.
He would get overruled or
they would listen to me.
It was,
it would,
it varied and in this I lost and in
this I think we created a bad product.
I don't think it represented fully the
the correct full explanation of what
contracts are.
I think because it's such a complex issue,
I think we owed a very complex
and scientific explanation.
But the problem is people
think that Shit's boring.
Like what I just said right now,
the majority of people listening
that would watch American idol,
but go pull,
what the fuck are you [inaudible]
podcast is not for everybody.
You know and this conversation
is not for everybody,
but if you want to make a TV show,
it kind of has to be for everybody for
the networks accepted until it becomes
really successful or find its niche.
And then people,
you know like South Park,
they can do whatever the fuck they want.
You know,
cause it's a proven product.
If you had another show,
we tried to make a cartoon where a gay
Guy Stuffing Paris Hilton up his ass and
winning a sloughed off,
they would go that's the
fuck are you talking about?
No you can't do that.
But South Park is so successful and is
so proven in the market that they do the
well when you show is not proven,
you really can't.
It's hard to like have your
say as to how things get done.
It's a complex dance and I
don't think we pulled it off,
but it's,
it's part of the thing
of creating something,
like when you try to create a show,
I feel personally responsible for it
though because a lot of people got angry
and I think a lot of that
anger could have been avoided.
When I first started
looking at chem trails,
uh,
online,
I too believe that it was a possibility.
Like is it possible to just point
us off right in front of our face?
They just spraying the sky.
But then the more you look into it,
you go,
no,
there's photos from 1980 that show these
contrail like long ones that lingered
in the sky.
People say,
when we were younger,
they didn't linger.
Actually they did.
You just don't remember.
Pay Attention.
How much the fuck do you pay attention
to clouds and created by jets when you're
eight,
you know,
can you really tell me exactly
what the fuck do you saw?
I barely remember shit I did last week.
I mean,
I'm being honest.
I barely remember important shit.
I did like shows that
I did that were great.
I got a standing ovation.
I barely remember them.
You tell me you remember this,
fucking,
these,
these contrails from when
you were eight years old.
I remember the foot.
Highly doubt.
It's a fucking remember that shit dude.
I learned stuff.
I learned some stuff from
Duane bank.com today,
man,
forget it either.
Man.
These people that I'm talking to,
there's a problem with doing this show
and this is why I don't know if I'm going
to continue doing it.
I mean,
first of all,
Scifi hasn't asked me to do it again,
but even if they do,
I have to really think about how it's,
I don't think I'm doing what I want to do.
I don't think it's coming out
the way I want it to come out.
It's,
um,
there's part of it that is like,
there was an episode we
did on transhumanism.
It's all complicated,
the science of extending human life.
And I love that because I got to talk to
all these super intelligent people and
pick their brain and ask really
important to me questions.
I'd love that,
but talking to people that are telling
me they're seeing bulletproof wolves and
go see shit that pops out of the grids
are little wormhole and out came a
bulletproof wolf.
Oh,
that sure happened.
I'm sure you didn't have a camera and you,
why would you,
while you're out there
hunting for bulletproof walls,
I just,
I got tired of it.
I got tired of talking to people that
are just crazy people or silly people or
people that need a fucking hug.
There's a lot of that out.
That's true.
Hundred percent and there's also a lot
of people that really believe what they
are saying and it's not
because they're assholes,
it's because they lack
critical thinking skills,
whether no one's taught it to them,
whether they've ignored them,
whether it's the way they were raised,
whether it's the
environment they grew up in,
whether it was the ideas they
were exposed to as a young person.
I don't know what has caused the
situation that we're talking about,
but there's a lot of people out there
that are thinking in a very piss poor way
and I've been one of them in the past.
Man,
I've been,
I've believed in a lot of
stupid shit in the past,
you know that I,
I was convinced probably was real.
There's a thing I was talking
about this a thing called rods.
These,
this,
this fucking,
they look like jellyfish that fly
through the air faster than you can see.
There's a whole video on them.
Roswell,
bronze.
Then I watched a show called monster
quest when they showed what they really
aren't.
It's just a video auto fact.
Like when you have a camera and it's
going on slow motion and something flies
past in front of it,
stretches the image out and make,
it's a blur.
It's fucking blur.
So I was convinced that these things
were flying through the air all around us
cause I'd seen this video and
I was like looking for him.
The guy who made this video does
not want to admit that they don't,
they don't exist.
Not only that,
he actually showed up at the UFC expo
when I was doing a Q and a and he asks,
he got in line and said he needed to
talk to me about Roswell rods and he's
coming on my podcast because they are
real and a though those people on monster
quest fucked him and they add,
I don't know how they could have fucked
them because they basically showed the
same scene.
There was a of a campfire or a light and
a bunch of bugs were flying in front of
light and they set two
cameras in front of it.
One of them was an HD super fast camera
to they use for like super slow mo and
the other one was like
a regular video camera.
Well the regular video
cameras showed these rods.
They are flying a crop
because it's an artifact.
And if you look at how it's
flying across the video,
it's not flying that fast.
Like I can see it.
So how can I not see it with my eyes,
but I could see it on camera.
And then the other one just
showed it's just bugs judge.
But did you see the
underwater ones and the space?
Real theories without a doubt.
Um,
information to government has been hiding.
Dude,
what you're doing right now is called you.
You're making a plea to
ridicule rods are just tiny.
Can trails.
Um,
yeah,
they,
they might as well do you know,
I thought they were real man.
I really did.
You know,
I,
I saw a video once it showed that there
were fucking buildings on the moon,
like to split this lucky guy
had he like had these images.
Oh,
even worse than that.
How about the face of Mars?
How about that motherfucker?
You ever see the face on Mars?
Yeah.
Well there's images that
people will swear to you.
The government is patiently doctor does.
Second more high resolution images.
There was some photos they took for
like a long time ago of Mars and as they
flew over Mars,
it shows what looks like a
five sided pyramid I think,
and a face,
a face on Mars.
Even my own friend who I loved dearly,
Graham Hancock wrote a dumb
ass book about all this shit.
I love this friend dear
they dumb ass dumb ass.
But he admits it was a mistake.
He admits it,
but shit,
that shit's important,
man.
It's clearly,
it's a faith if you look at the shape,
but it does not appear in nature.
This is either a two eyes pitch.
You don't know what the
fuck you're looking at.
Okay.
You're looking at a spot that you decide
that that's like looking at the clouds
and thinking that you see in dragons.
You know,
you also could be seen a fucked up
cloud because cloud's aren't perfect
symmetrical squares.
You Shit head.
All right,
and you're looking at some things that
you barely tell what the fuck you're
looking at.
Clearly it's the faith on Mars and there's
a dude who has these videos where he
measures like these arbitrary distances,
like a few measure from the nose to
the Left Front Center of that pyramid.
It is the exact same distance as
the Spanx to the pyramid of Giza.
And you're like,
how the fuck did you
come to that conclusion?
Yes.
If you look at it from the White House
and a 44 inch television in the corner
where Clinton used to get
his blow jobs from that room,
clearly the pyramid has a face on it
that looks like numbers on Mars and then,
and people fucking buy the DVD and call
each other on the phone and do this some
shit.
You got to see there's a man
who's dropping some truth,
some mad truth about the pyramid and
the next thing you know you're getting
fucking email blasts.
Have you seen this?
About The pyramid?
Like you mother fuckers,
it's not a fucking face on the Mars.
There might be,
but that's not it.
I mean,
there might be some other shit.
It doesn't mean there's not some Osha.
It matter of fact,
the pyramid shapes on Mars are
way more interesting than the,
um,
the face because the face when they show
the high resolution image of the face,
these are been doctored,
clearly doctored.
These are not high resolution photographs.
In fact they are.
And what less than half of the gigabytes.
And it would be if it was a true
85 gallon pickle fucking picture.
But there are some like symmetrical
objects that exist that do look like five,
sorry pyramids like you pull
up that because that was
kind of interesting to see
that.
Yeah.
But it's also possible that
those things exist naturally.
There's a lot of weird
shapes that exist naturally.
Like there's a,
there's this,
um,
I forget what it's called.
A giant something giant's causeway,
I think in Ireland.
Let me think if that's it.
Let me see if that's it.
But it's this crazy rock
formation that's totally natural.
Ireland I our wind,
I think that's what it is.
I need to get the images here.
Yeah,
that's it.
Go there.
Go,
go to giants causeway in Ireland and
tell me this shit doesn't look like some
mother fuckers were building a building,
but it's not.
It's not at all.
It's just some weird,
crazy natural formation.
If you saw this on an image of Mars,
if someone sent you this,
clearly these were cobblestones
on a a Martian street.
They have cars like Arvs.
They're probably shaped like us.
Go to that.
If you found it,
look at these images.
Look at this shit.
Look at that.
Where is this?
Oh,
this is an Ireland.
Tell me if you saw that on Mars,
you wouldn't start shitting your pants.
Yeah.
Clearly if we're so
sophisticated civilization,
that's just natural shit.
Perhaps aliens came down and ruin them.
Took their women.
Look at that.
I mean,
that Shit looks so wow.
That looks so unnatural.
Yeah,
100% it looks like someone made
a cool ass cobblestone streets,
but it's just a natural
formation when these,
I don't know what the fuck causes a stones
to be shaped in these weird patterns,
but look at that.
If you looked at that,
you would swear that has
to be made by somebody,
but it's not.
It's totally natural,
you know?
And there's varying stages of it.
They can actually see
like how it's developed.
I don't know.
I'm not,
obviously not,
what are they called?
What's the geologist?
Expert?
Someone who understands rocks.
You're a fucking human being.